vous en sortez non je suis désolé je ne
m'en sors pas mais parce que vous en
avez trop me mets tout fait exprès c'est
tout ce que je vais faire
en plus j'ai pas faim pourtant c'est
l'heure de manger
maintenant l'heure de manger c'est quand
on a faim moi j'ai toujours vendeur des
repas
attendez vous permettez mais au bout
mais on tripote - beauregard avec ses
doigts mais c'est pas grave mais on me
regarde ça avec le doigt ne me prenez
pas trop pour une fermière jeu reprit la
dernière fois que j'ai mangé de sa race
était sur park avenue le 20 janvier 93
le jour de l'investiture de clinton mais
enfin madame en scène vous avez laissé
cellophane autour du cheddar je les sais
quoi regardez il ya un papier au tour si
vous mangez ça comme ça vous allez vous
être anglais sont formidables et amis
auxerre en plus y'a même pas de cadeau
ben si
mais qu'est ce que vous pouvez
désagréable sais pas